it was one of the biggest miscarriages
of justice in british history hundreds
of lives shattered by a trusted
institution ordinary people accused of
crimes they didn't commit
people like joe hamilton wrongly
convicted of stealing 36 000 pounds
i was constantly shoveling money in and
remortgaging and borrowing money on
credit cards to pay bills and it it was
just never ending
my mum and dad aren't here to see it
either they weren't here to see my
conviction question and they literally
begged themselves to help me so
um that bit i can't get back
joe was accused of stealing because of
mistakes a computer was making a glitch
in the post office software horizon
like so many others wrongly accused
bankrupted even imprisoned she fought to
clear her name in court
and now the government still dogged by
questions about a state-owned company
have announced a compensation scheme to
be set up in the coming months
as well as apologies and accountability
people want proper compensation to be
paid those people who expose the scandal
in the first place the postmasters who
won the court case against the post
office have not been fairly compensated
back in 2019 a 58 million pound
settlement was agreed with more than 550
subpost masters that might sound like a
lot of money but once you take into
account legal costs most of them only
got back a fraction of what they've been
accused of stealing let alone the impact
on their lives being accused of a crime
they didn't commit
in a statement the post office accepted
most of that money didn't go to the
postmasters they said since it came to
light through media reports that around
46 million pounds of the compensation
provided to group litigation claimants
was directed to the funders of their
case we've continually urged the
government to address this unfairness we
welcome the government's announcement
that it will do so now they said
chris was accused of stealing 80 000
pounds he was compensated for around
twenty thousand
compensation will help put back the
finances you know to the position you
weigh and have this happen
the the inquiry and the accountability
will help show who knew what when so we
can you know some somebody has
made to to be
pay for what they've done
and it helps to turn uh i guess i said a
new leaf in the book to the next chapter
of people's lives
all the while the public inquiry goes on
i was so scared
for me it's just like post office or
authorities like a mafia
it's impossible to tell all of their
stories compensation won't make this
right but however late it does matter
ali fortescue sky news